es el peor mes de agosto desde el año
2010 y en el 99% de los casos los
incendios son atribuidos a la acción del
ser humano sobre la naturaleza es muy
raro que en esos bosques húmedos se
declaran incendios de forma natural el
fuego es utilizado en la amazonía por
distintos colectivos por ejemplo los
campesinos más pobres usa del fuego para
limpiar sus cultivos porque no tienen
dinero para comprar maquinaria agrícola
en algunos casos se les va de las manos
también hay ganaderos que usan el fuego
para crear nuevos pastos para el grado y
grupos criminales que provocan incendios
para protestar contra la protección que
brinda el estado a las reservas
indígenas y a los parques naturales
además muchos expertos denuncian que
desde 2019 desde la llegada al poder de
Jair bolsonaro la actividad ilegal en la
amazonía y los incendios aumentado
porque el discurso de bolsonaro en su
opinión estaría justificando la acción
criminal de esos grupos que se sienten
totalmente